so just one day after we got our hands
on these extraordinarily incriminating
tacks suggesting that Donald Trump's
lawyers henchmen I'm talking of course
of Rudy Giuliani's henchmen left Parnas
and Igor Froman after the texts exposed
that they had ambassador Murray
Ivanovich under physical surveillance
Nancy Pelosi in the House of
Representatives have moved forward with
the impeachment of Donald Trump sending
the two articles of impeachment over to
the United States Senate the vote to do
this was almost among party lines or
along party lines I guess I would say
228 to 193 the only Democrat Colin
Peterson to vote no was a guy who is
known as a Democrat in name only Collin
Peterson frequently grandstanding with
Republicans
despite being a Democrat in some
technical sense the house also voted to
approve seven impeachment managers now
these these are all Democrats of course
who are effectively going to act as sort
of prosecuting attorneys against Donald
Trump in the Senate trial this will be
explosive it's going to be ugly we're
going to talk about the proceedings and
what we can expect a little bit later
the seven impeachment managers that have
been selected are Adam Schiff Hakeem
Jeffries
Jason crow Jerry Nadler Sylvia Garcia
Val Demmings and Zoe Lofgren maybe the
most interesting inclusion in that list
is Jason crow from Colorado he's a first
term congressman he's not on the House
Judiciary or intelligence committees
from which every other impeachment
manager hails but the theme here is that
everybody who is going to be all seven
of these individuals have either law
degrees or law enforcement backgrounds
interestingly Zoe Lofgren has served in
all modern impeachment related
proceedings she was a staffer during the
Nixon pre impeachment which never became
an impeachment it ended up with his
resignation Nixon's resignation once it
became clear that impeachment would
likely lead to a conviction because
Republican voters and Republican senator
had abandoned him she was on the
Judiciary Committee Zoe Lofgren during
Bill Clinton's impeachment and here she
is again during Donald Trump's
impeachment the trial is tentatively
scheduled to start Tuesday but there is
going to be a lot of lead-up before what
you and I would consider the trial
actually gets going I'll talk about that
a little bit later we're still trying to
figure out what will be public what
might they push behind closed doors when
we know more we'll know more about what
we will or won't be live-streaming my
instinct is to stream as much of what is
public as possible and we'll talk about
that a little bit later on in the show
as well there are still questions about
what witnesses are going to be there
remember that well you need two-thirds
of the Senate to convict Trump 67
senators effectively which would be 45
Democrats the two independents that
caucus with Democrats plus 20
Republicans in order to convict Donald
Trump for subpoenaing witnesses for
agreeing to subpoena witnesses you only
need 51 you only need a simple majority
and that means you only need four
Republicans assuming all 47 Democrats
and independents are on board only four
Republicans need to agree to subpoena a
witness someone in order to make that
happen we've heard that MIT Romney wants
to hear from John Bolton
so is does that mean he would vote to
subpoena him that's one vote that he
would still need three more and then of
course the normal names are always
floated maybe lisa murkowski although
maybe not maybe Susan Collins although
often not maybe Cory Gardner although we
can't really say the same sort of
general questions apply to which
documents are going to be allowed
certainly the absolutely insane text
messages about Marie Ivanovitch being
under physical surveillance watching her
movements and relaying them back to left
Parnas that should be part of the trial
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
is absolutely going to try to keep those
documents out and of course Donald
Trump's immediate reaction was to start
tweeting
wacky stuff which we're going to look at
in a moment I I think this is a good
time to remember we we want to be
evidence-based and when we look at the
evidence
we shouldn't irrationally and
irrationally optimistically believe that
this is a process that's going to lead
to Donald Trump's conviction I know that
I still get emails from people saying
David don't assume as a foregone
conclusion that Donald Trump will be
acquitted in the Senate okay with 99%
certainty I've been reading a great book
called thinking and betts which says we
should we should talk more about
confidence with 99% certainty Donald
Trump is not going to be convicted in
this trial so therefore I'm going to try
to focus my analysis of the trial on the
basis that given that a conviction is so
unlikely what is the best setup for
ultimately helping to push Trump out of
the Oval Office by voting in November of
2020 ultimately removing him in January
of 2021 given that it is unlikely that a
conviction is at the tail end of this
what can Democrats do during the trial
how can they manage the obstructive
desires of Mitch McConnell and other
Republicans in the lead-up to the trial
to most damage Donald Trump that's the
lens I think is the most pragmatic one
if there are still people in my audience
who truly believe that the outcome of
this trial that is it we now know it's
not at some vague point in the future it
starts Tuesday unless something changes
if I still have people in my audience
who believe there could be a conviction
coming at the tail end of this I want to
hear from you I mean I want to hear
which 20 Republicans do you believe
might vote to convict or if you believe
that it's not about finding 20
Republicans but it's about something in
general will happen in the next couple
of weeks that will turn the entire
Republican Party against Donald Trump
I'm talking about his supporters because
that's what it would take to get
Republicans to abandon him get in touch
and explain to me exactly how you see
that happening what will be the catalyst
and in the meantime again Trump and his
family tweeting wacky stuff which is
what we're
look at next